[Music]
many people claim Muhammad was a prophet
of Peace who taught peace the best way
to determine whether or not that is true
is to look at what Muhammad himself said
in hadiths or reports about his words
and deeds that Muslims consider reliable
Muhammad said I have been commanded to
fight against people until they testify
that there is no God but Allah and that
Muhammad is the messenger of Allah
there's a threat attached in another
version of that Hadith which has
Muhammad saying I have been ordered to
fight the people till they say none has
the right to be worshiped but Allah and
if they say so pray like our prayers
face our kiah that is the direction for
prayer and Slaughter as we Slaughter
then their blood and property will be
sacred to us and we will not interfere
with them except legally their blood and
property will be sacred to us that is
left undisturbed instead of being killed
and their property seized Muhammad said
striving in the path of Allah that is
Jihad is incumbent on you along with
every ruler whether he is pious or
impious he also said know that paradise
is under the shades of
Swords Muhammad said fight in the name
of Allah and in the way of Allah fight
against those who disbelieve in Allah
make a holy war when you meet your
enemies who are polytheists invite them
to three courses of action if they
respond to any one of these you also
accept it and withhold yourself from
doing them any harm invite them to
accept Islam if they respond to you
accept it from them and desist from
fighting against them if they refuse to
accept Islam demand from them the gizia
if they agree to pay accept it from them
and hold off your hands if they refuse
to pay the tax seek Allah's help and
fight them Muhammad said the hour will
not be established until you fight with
the Jews and the stone behind which a
Jew will be hiding will say oh Muslim
there is a Jew hiding behind me come and
kill
him Muhammad said he who fights that
Allah's word Islam should be superior
fights in Allah's cause he said the
person who participates in holy battles
in Allah's cause and nothing compels him
to do so except belief in Allah and his
Apostle will be recompensed by Allah
either with a reward or booty if he
survives or or will be admitted to
Paradise if he is killed Muhammad said I
have been made Victorious with
Terror Muhammad was asked whether it was
permissible to attack enemy forces at
night if it would endanger their women
and children he replied they are from
them that is the women and children are
of the enemy so it's permissible to kill
them Muhammad said three things are the
roots of Faith to refrain from killing a
person who utters there is no God but
Allah and not to declare him unbeliever
whatever sin he commits and not to
excommunicate him from Islam for any of
his actions and Jihad will be performed
continuously since the day Allah sent me
as a prophet until the day the last
member of my community will fight with
the deal that is the Islamic idea of the
Antichrist Muhammad said I decided to
order a man to lead the prayer and then
take a flame to burn all those who had
not left their houses for the prayer
burning them alive inside their homes
Muhammad said kill any Jew Who falls
under your power Muhammad also said
killing unbelievers is a small matter to
us now remember Muhammad is the
excellent example for Muslims to imitate
according to the Quran and we see in all
the violence Muslims are today
perpetrating worldwide that indeed very
many Muslims are imitating Muhammad for
more information about this see this
website